السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره اعتقلت تسوطات الالمانيه 125
شخصا بينهم جنود سابقون ينتمون الى جماعه
من اقصى اليمين بتهمه الاعداد لاسقاط
الدوله وقالت الحكومه هنا المجموعه كانت
ثانوي على السلطه بالقوه وان شاء جيش
الموازن وتنفيذ هجمات داخل المانيا
تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي
رفضه المقترحه الروسيه تسليم قوات النظام
المناطق الحدوديه مع تركيا او تفكيك قوته
للتجنيب المنطقه عمليه عسكريه تركيه
قالت مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان وفد روسيا
برئاسه المبعوثه الروسي الى سوريا يتوجه
الى انقره لمناقشه الخيارات الشماليه
السوريه من جهته اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجي لافروف ان بلاده مهتمه بعمليه
استئناف الحوار بين تركيا وسوريا على اساس
اتفاق اضن على الذي يمنح ان اردت حقه تدخل
في سوريا لحمايته املها
اعلانات قوه المهام المشتركه التابعه
للتحالف الدولي التزام التحلل في بدعم من
وصفهم بشركائه فيما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه وسكاني شمال شرقي سوري سوريا
واقل منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي
ان الولايات المتحده ترفض العمليه التركيه
البريه المرتقبه في شماله سوريا
حمل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اوكرانيا مسؤوليه نشوب الحرب وقال انه لم
تحت اي فرص لتسويه الازمه واضاف بروتون
لعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا قد تتحول الى
عمليه طويله الامل
من جانبه قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال
الاطلسي
جانسيرج ان فرص السلامي في اوكرانيا
منعدمه حاليا
وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ما يحتاجه للدفاع عن بلاده لكنها لا
تشجعوا اوكرانيا على تنفيذ ضربات داخل
الاراضي الروسيه
ادت دينا بلا ورتي نائبه رئيس بيرو بيدرو
كاستيو ادت اليمين الدستوريه ترئيسه
انتقاليه للبلاد في عقاب قرار البرلمان
عزله الرئيس كاسيو بتهم الفساد والخيانه
وتعاهدت بولارسي بتشكيل حكومه وطنيه
الجامعه ودعت الى هدنه الناسيه لتجاوز
الازمه التي تشهدها البلاد وفي وقت سابق
اعتقلت اجهزه الشرطه في رواه الرئيس كاسيو
ووصفته في تغريده على تويتر بالرئيس
السابق وسرع انصار الرئيس سالي كاسيو الى
التظاهري امام البرلمان
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز لما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]